the future really is one of the major
solutions for our future water challenge
is going to be reuse of water and you
know there's often a negative
connotation to that people think Oh
toilet to tap we've heard a flush to
brush shower to flower so a lot of
different thoughts but really the beauty
of wastewater reuse is we can actually
purify that wastewater way beyond the
quality needed for for drinking water in
fact it's a nice consistent high quality
water no people don't have much issue
with desalination to be able to take
seawater and make drinking water and
actually waste water is much easier to
treat and then seawater but independent
of that that negative reaction to
wastewater reuse if you think about it
ninety percent of the world's water is
not used for human consumption or for
domestic use so we've got a great
opportunity to treat and reuse our
wastewater for agricultural irrigation
for industrial uses for a lot of other
uses before we ever get to the point
where we have to use it for you know
direct potable water reuse so today we
see a lot of adaptation of reuse water
to take the load off of streams and
rivers and freshwater supplies to be
used in industrial plants
related to water reuse is this idea of
waste to value how you take a waste
stream don't look at that as a as a
liability anymore there's a lot of
goodies in your in waste water for
instance in a municipal wastewater
system tremendous amount of carbon
content which you can convert to energy
so this idea of having a wastewater
plant that is that is carbon neutral or
actually generates you know more power
than it consumes of tremendous
opportunity phosphorus is a dwindling
resource globally yet there's a lot of
phosphorus and waste streams so there's
some cool technologies coming out
they're going to be able to selectively
remove things like phosphate or metals
like copper from a waste stream and be
able to process those into a finished
product so we need to stop thinking
about a wastewater stream as as pure
waste and look at that as a as an asset
not unlike we've been looking at you
know if you think about recycled
aluminum and plastic and all that used
to be a pure waste stream that's now raw
material for for other processes so
wastewater in the future will be a raw
material for many processes